we've been trying to get this guy out
for a while
um he he's uh made a lot of videos we've
enjoyed that we've uh
uh enjoyed on this program uh very funny
guy
very based uh barricade garage is
joining us today
barricade on the program as well yes
yes i believe i believe we have him here
hey that you there buddy we get the good
guests
looks like you're muted but i think you
could hear us
there he is hey what's up man
hold on one second nah do what you got
to do
all right let's see here boom there you
go
there you are hey we see you you're good
hey what's up what's going on man
welcome to the show finally man
thanks for being on want to get you on
for a while dude
yeah man it's i'm like a recluse i'm
like
i don't really like people so i gotta
warm up to people before i just start
jumping on dude that's why i got no
interviews out there
is that why all your sketches only have
you in them because you just can't work
with others
yeah that's that's that's one reason but
um
i mean it's pretty much i pretty much
took a model that i seen
other content creators doing and
condensing
um longer videos in the shorter videos
and then putting a comedic twist on it
and then putting it putting that out
and then doing it themselves as like a
form
of like entertainment that started going
viral back in the vine days so i just
took
that and i just started doing that with
politics and different
other ideas that i had but that's how i
started doing that so i i have a
question
at what point did you decide at some
point that you've just had enough
because you you said some pretty spicy
[ __ ] on your channel
and i like there are times where i'm
like this is a man
who's who's had enough
[Laughter]
man i mean so you know i started off
working on cars
i did my thing because i'm a mobile
mechanic and i was working in the shop
at the time so i wanted to do something
my first channel name was called
barricade bill
and i named it barricade after my jeep
because i went to go pick up this jeep
for eleven hundred dollars in baltimore
i picked it up it was night i was
looking at i was like yo it kind of
reminds me of barricade the transformer
boom barricade was born that's my jeep's
name
so i was doing little things for fixing
it up
and barricade bill so i started blogging
that record my repairs on that
outside of work and then before i knew
it
i started getting views on that and i
wanted to broaden my scope
and make it just about more stuff than
jeeps so then barricade garage came into
play
so a garage is just basically something
that it's a place you go to get your car
fixed
but it's also i say it in a sense that
men go to talk
and you know do other things like a
barber shop rack yard
etc so i just kept hearing about
the corona virus was my breaking point i
just kept hearing about all the [ __ ]
or did i know that i know to be fake
false phony
and what no one was really that i knew
of was really touching on the type of
things that i wanted to touch on
so i decided to come out
and and and talk about those things in a
way after
some of my favorite content creators
like caleb city king vader
and people like that so that's where my
first sketches came into play
and i had a passion for but at the time
my auto repair
following they didn't they didn't like
it like they didn't think it was funny
they didn't think it was funny so my
auto repair videos was getting like
thousands of views
my skits at first was getting like 50 60
views
but it was something i enjoyed doing i
didn't care about the money
that was where my heart was so it wasn't
until
well y'all know the story how i blew up
you know sometimes it takes somebody
bigger than you
to put you on or to notice you or
mention you
in order to share you on their community
post and put their subscriber base on to
you
now you got to instant following and i
just went up from there
but the same people that uh that was
sharing my work
they found out that i'm not
tamed no
you know you can't just stuff me in a
box
because i'm not going to adhere to the
rules that you want me to follow
so now i'm kind of
here doing what i still do and you know
that's
that's pretty much how it started though
and i you know it's funny you say that
because that was
that's what i was going to bring up next
is i i i do we do find and i'm
sure you know this with a lot of people
like you know they blow up in a
subscriber base like let's take a ben
shapiro retweet you for example let's
use him as an
as an example he retweets you and then a
lot of these people they
they just kind of morph to the will of
that community
where it's like oh okay well i need a
pander this way and i need to pander
this
i need a i i need to have these sets of
views like i was actually watching your
live stream
i think it was yesterday when you were
you were calling out republicans you're
like how can you be the party of free
speech and then you know
not stand up for the clan and how can
you and i thought that have you gotten a
lot of backlash from people
like oh so you know republicans are
actually great uh
for example you're you're you you did a
video yesterday where you were talking
about how capitalism leads into
socialism right
right and i saw a lot of people were not
happy with that statement
no they weren't happy but see when you
got somebody like me who was dealt with
real adversity i'm not scared of what
the naysayers and people in the comment
section
i'm not scared of my own subscriber base
and just because you like me
doesn't mean i'm not gonna like somebody
that you don't like
i'm not scared to to to
blend between those lines if that's the
word i'm looking for but
my thoughts is i speak my
thoughts because a lot of people are
scared to do that and i feel like
the conversation has become so
kindergarten that when somebody like me
comes on and says the things that i say
those same people who champion free
speech they'll often need a safe space
so now you got to run
away with jp channel get some of that
type of calm it's safe
you see what i'm saying because i'ma say
things i may talk about you
or i'ma say things that make you think
now a lot of people didn't like the
video
on my capitalism leads to socialism but
i wasn't saying it it's a definite
like that's what a hardcore but i was
just sharing my thoughts and in the
community of individuals
you have those type of philosophers that
share ideas like that like i'm noticing
a pattern i didn't read a book on that
there's nobody i follow who stated that
as a matter of fact before i did it i
felt like i get a lot of backlash
from my own base because they're mostly
conservative
for even pointing out some things in
capitalism
but like a lot of people say they don't
feel like this is truly capitalism
some of them double downs like yeah it
is capitalism but what you can't deny
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] up and everybody can
be bought i just use youtubers
on a small scale like that to show you
how on a bigger scale
things can get out of control when you
when the love of money is in your heart
another thing about my free speech video
i didn't touch on
is the israel topic a lot of people
a lot of people will say well well i
know for a fact a lot of to serve they
don't like that
oh they'll tanks and the funny thing is
is it's even if you just say the word
they go ooh
and everyone starts looking down they
look at their i haven't even said
anything yet
i just said israel and everybody's like
hey i'm out i'm out of this conversation
i got to go count my super chats
[Laughter]
yeah and that's that's how it'll be but
i feel like when i feel like to to open
up people's minds and
and and expose people to to to
ideas in order to like find solutions to
combat certain [ __ ] some [ __ ] you gotta
pill
you gotta peel the band-aid off of
certain wounds and expose it let it get
some air
so i'm talking about it and it's not
that i'm anti-semitic i don't
hate jews but at the same time
of course i'm gonna talk about it
because i do have a community aspect to
me and you're not supposed to talk about
so i'ma talk about it because it's taboo
because i feel like comedy comes from a
place of darkness no
not that i hate jews i don't hate jews
i'ma talk [ __ ] about them just like i
talk [ __ ] about black people everybody
know that
white people y'all gonna get it the same
way it's equality
you know it's it's true because that
that's the way that i see it too it's
like whenever
whenever somebody tells you don't talk
about this don't talk about this don't
talk about this like
i think i don't know if it is anymore
but i think it used to be human instinct
of like that's all i want to talk about
now
like i wouldn't even thought about it
but when when when
when when a big group of people starts
telling you like oh you know you can't
criticize these people
then you go well wait a second why not
and then honestly i think it kind of
fuels the fire more it's like
oh so the people that control the media
and tv and everything are telling you
you're not allowed to talk about them
it makes you it makes me uneasy you know
we're like well why can't we joke about
this like you could joke about
anything that you want you could put
martin lawrence in a [ __ ] dress and
that's hilarious
but the moment you [ __ ] you [ __ ] say
you you say like hey you know maybe
we're giving a little bit too much to
israel it's like oh what are you
anti-semitic you don't believe the
holocaust happening like whoa well relax
i mean not me i don't but see people are
getting my [ __ ] about that
it's a lot of [ __ ] with that then
when you start banning speech around it
you start you start having penalties
like jail time for
questioning it then now it's like now i
gotta talk about it
but see the problem is what they do to
us
is they'll let black people somebody
black like me
say those type of thing so my white
you can't say those type of things yo
[ __ ] delete it
and i think that too enforces the victim
narrative now they're earth bending us
it's like they'll prop up
one group and when that when their time
comes
silence bring them down bring up the
next group
and when their time comes silence gone
now you got black nationalists
white nationalists now is the time for
one group and not the time for the next
group pretty soon
it's not going to be the time for no
group because nobody stands up for free
speech
no i mean and that and that's and that's
exactly the point like you know we
we talk about like for example like
crenshaw who's like oh everything's free
speech and then when he started telling
people like
hey don't question israel you're going
to regret that you said that it's like
what happened mr free speech you're not
that free speech
yeah when he's sending veiled threats to
college kids it's like okay dude why
don't you call
he's literally like just like veiled
threats like he's the godfather on
twitter
yeah and i'm like you're tagging college
kids like you're a congressman from
texas you're bullying college kids like
you're a you're a veteran for [ __ ]
sake
like it's insane yeah so that i want to
touch something you brought up which i
think is a really good point
do you think you get away with more
because you're in what they perceive a
protected class
like do you think but yeah you're
absolutely right
the certain type of black people get
away with it's not all of them
certain they they choose they pick and
choose that's why i say they they're
earth bending us
like they'll raise them up and lower
some down that that keeps you
even more divided so now you got
somebody saying the exact same things
you believe
and you want to say but you gotta hate
on him because you can't say it
and that keeps you mad it's your fellow
countrymen instead of the people
manipulating the speech
it's just like how i did the live stream
and i was talking about the word
perfectly acceptable word
back in slavery wasn't no slave or no
slave
mad that master called them
if slain got to run away answer
hop out stop that
i mean it wasn't like the slave stopped
it was like
nobody wasn't dignity it was the action
behind the word it wasn't even the word
fast forward they they manipulate and
change what's acceptable and what's not
they manipulate culture fast forward we
have the word negro
you see all types of tapes with malcolm
x he doing interviews
and the white man is calling him a negro
now you get on tv you can't say negro
you can't say that now now they're
saying people of color
because they're back to calling us color
like it was the time you couldn't say
that that was offensive
yeah and now they're using now they're
saying masculist party-goers you know
what i mean they're always changing
right it's confusing so they're going to
manipulate the speech
and they're going to change definitions
to suit their agendas
and you got to be wise to see through
that that's why i said what we need is
understanding that's why i'm not i'm not
a sellout
i'm not a call i'm not none of these
things because i've actually been in the
position
for which to defend my ideas and what i
believe in
that's why i told like they want to say
i'm a [ __ ] you can't say that until you
stand in a room
full of angry white people that's built
like nappa from dragon ball z
and tell them imma beat the [ __ ] out of
you because you oppressing me
won't they do that i did that [ __ ]
i was about that [ __ ] and when you do it
you get no satisfaction from it
you can see through the [ __ ] you got
to go through some [ __ ]
to see through the [ __ ] that's why i
can say what a hard er
and people get mad oh don't say that
conservatives don't like this [ __ ]
don't say that you're enabling white
people to say that i don't give a [ __ ]
they gonna say what they want you think
the white people say i ain't saying it
because you said don't say it
and everybody's saying that [ __ ] and
that's and that's you know it's that's
the biggest problem
i know you touch a little bit of uh one
of your live streams but that's the
biggest problem
i think with conservatives or
republicans is that
they have no teeth like they they never
have no teeth
they want to talk about free speech and
they want to talk about all this but you
people remember that not long ago it was
conservatives that were telling you
you know put a parental advisory rapp
music is evil it's like it's all the
same thing it's just a back and forth
and it's it's like oh no we want free
free free speech free speech
but if if lindsey graham were to come
out and drop an n-bomb
no conservative is going to stand up for
him nobody they're not going to go oh
leave him alone be like
what he did was wrong and it was racist
and they're not they don't
they they they want they talk about free
speech but in the end
if you really want to believe in free
speech like look at the aclu is a great
example the aclu now is a [ __ ]
joke the aclu used to defend the clan
marching in kentucky they'd be like
they have a right to do it and that
that's really defending speech nobody
defends speech anymore
yeah and i would say lindsey graham
strikes me as the kind of guy that
always has an n-word like loaded in the
chamber
oh yeah like it's always ready to go you
know what i mean and he's done a good
job for 30 years of not saying it
but don't don't [ __ ] don't get it [ __ ]
up he's got one in the chamber at all
times
he does talk like a gay plantation owner
no he really does i feel like people
should just be like fanning him and
feeding them like [ __ ] he's handing him
mint juleps and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
nah that's that's i feel that way about
a lot of people but um
like i was watching this video today
earlier on youtube
and uh the title was white woman doesn't
apologize
for using the n-word and they showed the
scenario
it was like a [ __ ] waffle house
somewhere in the south of course
you had keisha and shaquita they was
over there i don't know the [ __ ]
names i don't know
they was over here being unruly as [ __ ]
right
so the um the older white room she
watched you like yo can you keep it down
please
and boom please she got mad she was like
a cracker and she was like you're a
stupid then she walked off
so look all the [ __ ] now you got
shaquita oh no they
didn't and then i don't know how the
[ __ ] the news cameras always catch up to
these people but they catch up put a
camera in her face it was like do you
apologize for calling keisha
she was like no she was like the news
anchor was like well do you realize that
that's offensive and she was like [ __ ]
it that's why i said it
to offend them because they offended me
and i feel like if you're in the
argument you're supposed to say the most
offensive [ __ ]
possible you know that's a button for
them
so i'm gonna call you don't make you a
racist
it don't mean you hate black people you
just
now i see it like that certain people
don't and that's their prerogative but
um
where you i think we could all agree
though that it is disappointing to hear
people looking down on other races in a
waffle house because frankly you're all
in a waffle house
right so you know what i mean like
nobody should really be flinging any
insults based on race or religion you're
literally all in a waffle house at three
in the morning
you've made some bad decisions in your
life don't be [ __ ] throwing stones
from your glass waffle house
exactly and uh
i was why i [ __ ] with you from a while
back
before i even knew about y'all because i
had a subscriber they they subscribe to
you guys
they came on my channel it was like oh
rotc
i kept saying i was like what the [ __ ]
is the rotc it's like revenge of the
says
they talk about so i went on there and
like
the first the the um
that video you did you played my video
yeah yeah i like to stick around and
then you made the joke
about the hearts twins
oh yeah do you not know i was on the
floor
laughing my ass [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
legendary
if you sit like that did it get you
canceled
but that [ __ ] is funny the world needs
[ __ ] like that
we used to be able to joke with each
other like that
nowadays you won't have more white
people offended you said that
than black people and that's what's
crazy but that [ __ ] was funny
so i was like yo i like this guy
y'all didn't disappoint i heard you
talking about um
you sound just like fouchy too i heard
him on earlier y'all was covering one of
his videos yeah
and then when i went to look you up here
you go talk about [ __ ] nicole arbor i
can't stand this [ __ ] needs to get
better equipment
look at this [ __ ] she has a punchable
face and then you you sit up here you
play i know you [ __ ] hate nicole
arbor then you play
fouchy and [ __ ] falci we need to
accept we need to reassess the data and
figure out that we have
we have these [ __ ] a group of people we
need the
he's sitting there straight he sounds
just like you i was like yo that's merch
y'all sounded like i i i do have uh
sort of like the the roger rabbit
syndrome where i know
i know i'll get in trouble for saying
something but if it's funny it's like i
can't it's a helpful thing it's
literally like the scene where he's
tapping and doing shaving a haircut and
i'm just going i
i gotta [ __ ] it i have to do it i have
to do it it's like i can't control it
so yeah i did say that the hodge twins
reminded me of escape slaves but
they should have kind of a charm to them
but the thing is too when people take it
personally
and like we have a lot of people that
hate the show because we'll mock them or
we'll make fun of them but in the same
regard like if i met the hodge twins
somewhere i'd buy him a drink i'd say
hello you know what i mean like
it's like people take the [ __ ] we say
and they go oh i bet you hate those guys
and i'm like
no i'm just looking at what's in front
of me and i'm goofing on it it's the
same way as like
mystery science theater 3000 i don't
think they hated any of those filmmakers
you're just watching it and goofing on
it but if i meet any of those people i'd
be like
yeah what's up man let me buy you a
drink like sorry i goofed on you it's
just kind of what i do
[Laughter]
that's how i took it i took it as
entertainment but it is funny because
you need different opinions like that on
some
certain things like sometimes y'all do
something y'all run a piece
that'll be massively popular and y'all
come in and criticize that [ __ ] that's
balance i love it i [ __ ] like like
people hate me make a video about me
i might want to hear it people say i
don't read comments because people be
saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] about you
i read them [ __ ] some people be hurting
my [ __ ] feelings that [ __ ]
i read that [ __ ] i listen i learn
i may not read all of them but i do but
we need violence like that just like
when y'all was talking about tom
mcdonald video
a lot of people don't hate you for not
liking that
it's like everybody don't have have to
like everything
something some people you just don't
[ __ ] like
some people you want to punch out some
people you talk about but you still like
them
some of your family members that way of
course you hate them but you love them
you talk about them but you still punch
them out
that's how me and my sister are we got a
great relationship but i see myself
punching around a couple times
throughout the course of our
relationship
that's how it is we need that balance
that's why i like that that's why i
watch the show
yeah you know it it's funny because the
term that i think that i'm
[ __ ] so sick of hearing the most is
because we goof on everybody right
and i s i'm sick of people saying like
don't punch right
don't punch right i'm like i don't give
a [ __ ] if tom mcdonald's gonna be out
there like
look at a [ __ ] we're going to make fun
of him you know what i mean like
it it's it's that it's that tom mcdonald
is a great example because
we brought that up it's like everyone's
like look how basty he's like no the
[ __ ] he's not
he's doing [ __ ] ben shapiro and
crowder talking point
he's not really in my opinion not
talking about what if he was re like we
look that's why we we we talked about it
with you it's like
you say what's on your [ __ ] mind it
doesn't matter what anybody thinks
it doesn't matter what anybody says tom
mcdonald is always
like oh the elites yeah but who are the
elites tom be specific
tom mcdonald is just charlie kirk with
face tattoos
that's all he is you know what i mean
like that's well he is
that's hurtful hey kirkwood and maybe
larger teeth
yeah y'all good cop bad cops [ __ ] royce
come in with the balance he give people
a chance
and then here comes merch sounded like
fouchy you just obliterate people
i'm the one that beats you with a phone
book while you're handcuffed to a table
yeah i know and then i walk in and i go
hey sorry man merch is a hot shot look i
want to get you out of here
what do you want you want a sprite you
want some burger king we'll get you out
of here we'll get you out of here
you don't want merch to come back in
merch wants off the leash on this one
and i said look man
you know [ __ ] it
royce with the newport 100s and here
comes merch with the right hook
that's y'all
royce is the one that comes up to you
and goes hey man you got the time and
then i'm the one that comes up and just
bow
straight and go three pockets [ __ ]
balance